-One box...
of transcripts that I have.
-Are you kidding me?
-Like, it's hundreds
of thousands of pages.
I'm trying to ask all my friends
to make these audios
come alive.
And I'm trying to turn it into
kind of, like,
a play with voices.
A community looking back.
And so that's what I'm doing
here with you,
and Sammy Rockwell's gonna read
the director
of "Cool Hand Luke."
Laura Linney is gonna do
Joanne Woodward.
Zoe Kazan is gonna play
Paul's first wife.
Karen Allen is playing
Joanne's stepmother.
Josh Hamilton is gonna read
the director of "The Sting."
Vincent D'Onofrio is gonna do
John Huston.
George Clooney agreed to read
Paul.
So, we're having fun
kind of revisiting
the generation before us.
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Ethan Hawke,
everybody.
That was a clip from
"The Last Movie Stars."
So, one, you're making this
during a pandemic,
but that's not the only reason
you reach out to your group
of friends who are actors.
You had another reason
that you asked them all
to do voice-over work in this.
-Well, the family had
an amazing thing.
It was this -- you see it
in that clip right there.
They had transcriptions
of interviews
that Paul had done
to write his own memoir.
He had had his best friend
interview
all his closest friends,
nannies, co-workers,
best friends, everybody
that knew them well.
But he never wrote the memoir.
So, these interviews
were sitting there
'cause he got bored
with the whole idea once
and just set them on fire,
destroyed them,
got rid of them.
But the transcripts
still exist.
But I was so frustrated
when I took this job
and I was like,
"If I had the audiotapes,
I could make a really great
film, but I don't."
And then I had the idea --
well, I am an actor,
and it is an international
pandemic,
and nobody's doing anything,
and so I'll just reenact
these interviews.
And then I'll have
the audiotapes,
of which I could
cut them together.
So, you see, that's what
I'm talking about there
in that video,
and it ended up being
really fun because the movie
is a meditation on acting
and I'm using actors to guide
you through that meditation.
-And it's really nice
and natural.
Like I was saying
to you backstage,
like, at first, it's, "Oh, this
is such a strange construct."
But then you immediately
become...
I don't know, it's really...
You know, when George Clooney
is reading Paul Newman,
it just seems to make
perfect sense.
-Just starts to flow.
I remember...
Scorsese is exec producer
on this
and he was giving me notes
and he was like,
"I started watching this,
and for about five minutes,
I thought you lost your mind."
[ Laughter ]
"I don't want to see another
Zoom call as long as I live."
-Yeah.
-"And then I thought,
'Wait, I think
this is working.'"
And I was like, "Yeah, yeah.
Alright, we got it. We got it."
-It made me really happy
when Scorsese showed up
because the first five minutes,
I thought,
"God, no actor knows how
to light their own Zoom,"
and even Scorsese
looks bad on Zoom.
[ Laughter ]
-He looks better than most.
-He looks better than most,
but it's not great.
Yeah.
You met Paul Newman
exactly one time.
-One time.
-And with kind of high stakes,
I will say.
-Very high stakes.
I was doing
a Tennessee Williams play.
The play actually had been
written for Paul Newman
back in the '50s.
It's called "Camino Real," and
he and Joanne came to see it.
And I remember
I was really
sitting
in my dressing room mirror
and they...
[ Laughter ]
There's, like, a gremlin
down there grabbing my arm.
[ Laughter ]
They were standing behind me
and I couldn't believe,
there they were,
and he was talking about
doing "Sweet Bird of Youth"
and he'd been in
the original production.
And I'm just staring at them.
And he said the first time
he met Tennessee,
he said, you know,
"Nice to meet you,"
and Tennessee said,
"Oh, yeah, nice to meet you."
And Paul said, "Well, actually,
we have met before."
Tennessee said, "Oh, no,
I would remember."
And he said, "Well, no,
I auditioned for you
several times,"
And Tennessee said,
"Mm. Turn around."
And he looked at his butt
and went, "Oh, yes!
Now I remember you."
[ Laughter ]
But, see, you have to imagine
Paul Newman was telling me
that story, right behind me.
-Yeah.
-And I often thought about it
as I was cutting
the documentary.
What would he think if he knew
that his kids gave me,
you know, the responsibility
of telling his story?
He'd be like, "That punk kid?"
-Well, I think if he saw
the actual finished product,
he'd be pretty happy about it.
-I hope so.
-Yeah.
-I really hope so.
-Hey, man, congratulations
on this.
It's just always such a delight
to have you here,
and so much so that we tried
to trap you on your chair.
-Yeah, I think
I'll be stuck here.
I'll be here
for the next person.
-We'll switch the seats.
Thanks, buddy.
Great to see you.
Ethan Hawke!
"The Last Movie Stars"
is streaming now on HBO Max.